it's great to be joined today by Josh
Zepps who you may know as a founding
host producer of HuffPost live he now
has the agressively BS free funny
conversations with big names on his
smash hit podcast We the People live
so Josh this I've seen the I've listened
to the podcast for people who aren't
familiar with it when you say
aggressively BS free what does that mean
well I don't say aggressively P is free
I use the actual wood right yeah we have
unfortunately the FCC we we have to pay
attention to still damn them can I say
damn them at least David can I at least
say that I'm told that's okay yeah well
I think that there is a huge amount of
pandering in the media at the moment on
both sides of politics and so when I say
aggressively bs3 I just mean that I felt
like there was a space in the media for
conversations that that didn't
immediately put the interlocutors you
know in a prism of of a particular
political paradigm or another I mean
it's astounding to me that you can you
can you can tell me a certain set of
beliefs that a person holds in America
in the 21st century and I will with
fairly good accuracy predict a whole
host of completely unrelated other
beliefs right if you tell me that
someone is a climate science denial I
can probably tell you what their opinion
is about taxes why I mean this is
ridiculous why do we have Wyatt why is
there a while why are we choosing from
grab bag a or grab bag B it strikes me
that if you want to be intellectually
honest then what you should be doing is
as a person in the media is having
open-ended inquisitive non-judgmental
conversations with people with all kinds
of different ideas and trying to cobble
together whatever that makes the most
sense and doing it in a light-hearted
way that's why I sort of talk about I
don't mean aggressive in a way that's
overbearing I mean aggressive in a way
that is aggressively committed to truth
justice all those kinds of principles
that we hope that journalists would show
more of okay so let's let's dig into
that a little bit because I I agree with
everything you've said however I want to
explore whether you think that this is
an issue or some of the issues you deal
with particularly the disconnect from
science is equally problematic on both
sides of the political spectrum or call
it off no I do or call it a pattern or
whatever because sometimes we
here this this meme of hey it's just as
bad on both sides you've got ideologues
on both sides etc when you look at an
issue like climate science denial it's
not really both sides yeah yeah no I
completely agree there's I didn't I
didn't mean to convey that that
impression that it's equally bad in
turning a partisan sense right so the
Republican Party in the United States
has become more unhinged to facts in
most fields of public policy then I
think any major party in any developed
country at the moment and certainly in
comparison to the way the Republican
Party was just a few decades here as
well but when I say both sides I simply
mean that we're all capable of fooling
ourselves we're all capable of cognitive
biases of only paying attention to
things that already suit our
preconceived notions are feeling morally
self-righteous like I think for example
moral self-righteousness is something
that you will find more of in my opinion
on the left paradoxically it's a trait
that we associate often with the right
we think that the writer that the
Conservatives are much more into feeling
morally superior to other people but
when I look at the way that the left has
responded to the challenge of having an
idiot in the White House and a corrupt
administration I don't see a huge amount
of nuance and an attention being focused
on the things that really matter I do
see a huge amount of moral superiority
maybe justifiably but you're not gonna
win over the middle by simply asserting
your own moral superiority I see a huge
amount of identitarian politics I see a
huge amount of groupthink so you're
right I'm not drawing a false
equivalence and saying that you know
Democrats are just as bad as Republicans
in the United States in 2017 the
Republicans are uniquely pernicious but
I don't think that gets us anywhere on
the left to just continue to try to ram
that home if what we want to do when
everything went over the 35% of people
who still support Donald Trump if we're
gonna win over the middle then we have
to be the adults in the room who are who
are recognizing our own fallibilities
and frailties as well and much of that
bad thinking exists on the left too so
I've said something similar to what you
just said which is at this point if
you're still on the gallop daily
tracking poll in that 35 or so percent
that approves of the job Donald Trump is
doing I increasingly believe that you
were effectively beyond reach and Furman
from an electoral standpoint
I don't think it makes sense to try to
appeal to that 35% I think the time it
would take you to convince one person
within that 35% that maybe their vote
for Trump was a bad idea you might be
able to get five or ten people who don't
vote given that only one in two
Americans actually vote to vote in 2018
or 2020 so that that's my view from a
purely pragmatic standpoint do you agree
with that yes totally
totally I mean I'm not even sure that
it's that new David is it I mean no I
think there's always been just a rusted
hardened core of partisans who are
highly ideological and you know their
parents have voted a certain way their
grandparents are vote a certain way
their identity is bound up in a
particular political party this is true
not just in the United States but all
over the world I mean look what's look
at Syria you know look at Iraq these are
there are deeply embedded woven
identities that are that are you know
obviously over there they can be ethnic
and religious as well but here they cut
along along class lines they cut along
race lines and they certainly cut along
partisan political lines and I don't see
the point in in either trying to win
over or demonize people who are never
going to agree with you anyway it's
dundar to just regard them as a lost
cause and let's play in the winnable
space and what we're doing at the moment
I think on the left is not not doing
nearly enough playing in the winnable
space what's an example of how the left
could better play in the winnable space
like as specifically as possible Islam
is one that I keep going on about I
think that it's it's it's taken a long
time for us to speak frankly about
terrorism and about legitimate concerns
that people have about conservative
Islam and whether or not you can
maintain the openness of a Western
liberal progressive democracy that
upholds feminism and gay rights and so
on if you're going to import very very
large numbers of people from extremely
floor mattias regions who adhere to a
set of beliefs that tend to be deeply
conservative or much more conservative
than the mainstream in Western liberal
democracies and I think the the refusal
to grapple with that honestly and to
once again have a BS tree and
aggressively be as free conversation but
is both tolerant towards Muslims
respectful of belief but also
understanding frank about
the fact that a low information voters
who knows no no one is under any
illusions no matter how uneducated they
are that there is a religious motivation
behind jihadist terrorism right you want
simply by saying Islam is a religion of
peace and there is no problem here and
we're all one under God is not going to
convince the low information voters who
sees the trucks barreling down the
boulevard in Nice and he is that the
people jumped who jumped out of the
trucks were shrieking Allahu Akbar but
this is one area where I think we can do
more to reach across the aisle
I think race and identity politics is
obviously the flashpoint at the moment
there's a huge debate on the left you
know about what should we stand for
should we be standing for better
equality for everybody or should we be
descending into identitarian squabbles
in a kind of zero-sum thinking and I
think part of the part of the Trump
backlash I mean I'm not the first to
acknowledge this is a politics of white
identitarian resentment that is a
reaction to the the kind of fashionable
political correctness of the list as its
perceived by those people so there would
be two areas things like terrorism
security and things like identity
politics where we just need to stop
being such smart asses frankly so I I
agree with you on both of those issues
the question I have is more how do you
turn that into policy positions and
stump speeches because ultimately if
people on the Left can't win with
sensible positions in those areas it's
almost as if they don't exist so how do
you turn that into a workable campaign
without alienating some significant
portion of the left well remember that
the flip side of the point that you made
earlier about abandoning any hope of
winning over the 35% of people who are
still voting for Trump is that you can
afford to alienate the 35% of people who
will vote Democrat regardless hmm right
so you don't worry too much about
alienating you know the it the trans
lesbian black female vote is not going
to be voting for the Republicans I can
you know a newsflash so you can you know
don't mean to sound callous but you can
basically take them for granted the
people who have to win over are the
other people in the middle so when I
think you're right David to talk about
tone and and how do you sell it because
if 2016 was anything it was a kind of an
apotheosis of two different visions of
how political speech can happen I mean
Trump was a was a wrestler in the ring
smashing a chair over everybody's head
and not in the proverbial sense in the
literal sense and Hillary Clinton was
the most polished professional studied
candidate in our lifetimes right I mean
I can't imagine a person more
professional than her and we have
reached a time and part of what I'm
trying to do on my on my podcast is to
have conversations where again people
feel free and liberated to step outside
of sound bites and to talk about what
their what they actually feel and what
they actually believe how do we get
politicians to feel free to do that and
how do we create a climate in which
we're not constantly jumping down
people's throats I mean you know like I
mentioned I mentioned race and I
mentioned Islam these are areas where
there are things that I could say that
we all know to be true right now that
would trigger trip wires that would
instantaneously be interpreted in bad
faith by people on the left as being an
indication that I'm a bigger if I said
anything negative about black lives
matter or so on then the mere fact of us
being two white people would disqualify
us from having an open conversation
about that that's what I think has to
stop and when political candidates can
stop thinking that way can stop
tiptoeing around on eggshells the way
that Hillary Clinton did if we can find
someone on the left on the progressive
left who is in favor of innovation and
in favor of of the things that made
America great but also has compassion
and has vision and can articulate that
vision in a way in a sort of Trumpy way
I don't know who that person is but I
can imagine that happening I think the
first step is just to throw out the cue
cards and have honest conversations
about things and and for us as citizens
and as journalists and as media
commentators to quit this BS of jumping
down everybody's throats because they
said something slightly wrong or
something slightly provocative or they
didn't you know they didn't side with
with the the correct team line
appropriately that's got to stop let me
shift gears a little bit
last week I interviewed David McAfee who
has a new book called no sacred cows
where he talks about all even though
we've seen reduced literal religious
belief over time we actually have an
increased belief in paranormal ghosts
various types of conspiracy theories
that border on the paranormal etc can
you talk a little bit about what you see
going on right now within the sort of
debunking and skeptic community we know
that religious adherence is on the
decline can you tell me the similarities
and differences between literal
religious beliefs and sort of UFO belief
or the idea of some of these other
conspiracy theories are there are there
lines between these beliefs yeah and
this is one area where when you said you
know you pointed out that we shouldn't
be making a false equivalency between
lies on the left and lies on the right
this is one area where the left is
particularly bad I think the left is
particularly susceptible to mumbo-jumbo
about genetically modified food two
fears about vaccines two just unfounded
ideas about organic products for example
homeopathy things like that um as you
may be aware but might but your viewers
probably aren't I have quite a lot to do
with the Richard Dawkins foundation I
was the host of their podcast for well
it was the Center for inquiry before
that for the past four years and so I
moderated a few of Richard Dawkins
events when he's in the United States
and this is a subject that's close to
his heart as well and we've spoken at
length about the the odd way in which
superstitions just get substituted right
you you leave you see a society leaving
formal dogma behind becoming less
overtly religious and church attendance
going down example and at the same time
you see a lot of other kind of
superstitions rise so there's got to be
some correlation here and also I mean I
think we can stretch this to political
myths as well I mean the Republican
fixation on the idea that if you cut
taxes you're not going to cut revenue
because you're going to give such a
boost to the economy then it'll make up
the difference is just it's it that is
as mumbo-jumbo II as vaccines causing
autism right it's it's sort of
politically convenient thinking I
honestly don't
my aspiration I suppose is that where is
that it's possible to nudge ourselves
into being somewhat more reasonable on
all fronts and we don't have to
substitute one form of idiocy for
another and there are countries that do
that fairly well I mean my mum's from
New Zealand you go to New Zealand this
just not a lot of BS I lived in I
studied in Copenhagen in Denmark for for
a semester
when I was in my early 20s and you know
it seems like people are non-religious
there and also not crazy how do we get
there your guess is as good as mine
interesting and can you talk a little
bit more specifically about is there
operationally you know last week I did a
story about a Republican who believes
that when she was 7 she was abducted by
aliens and that since then they've
telepathically communicated with her and
she says she's also a Christian and the
belief presumably that Jesus was born to
a woman who never had sex nobody's
talking about the fact that presumably
she believes that but they are talking
about the fact that she says she was
abducted by aliens when she was 7 are
those believe differently disconnected
from reality
well I think the I think your
implication is embedded in the question
right they're not they're not one is not
less plausible I mean if anything the
alien claim is somewhat more plausible
to me just because I mean I think it's
unlikely that aliens have visited planet
Earth but epistemologically
her claim hot carries more water because
there's more ground she herself has more
grounds to believe it right I mean she
she is retelling an experience she is
not claiming to know something about
what happened in the Middle East 2,000
years ago I mean I was in church the day
before yesterday because my
brother-in-law was getting married and
you know the the idea that the priest
was putting forward that because he was
saying certain words over a wafer it was
bodily turning into the flesh of a man
who lived in Palestine 2,000 years ago
if if you if you didn't know about
Christianity and you they discovered
some new tribe in Papua New Guinea that
believed the same thing you would look
down your nose with condescension and
chuckle and think about how much better
Western civilization is than the
primitive savages who believe such
nonsense
I mean the idea of the Virgin Mary you
know you can't even know for sure today
whether or not a woman is a virgin if
you're if you've been alive then you
wouldn't have been able to assert that
she was a virgin when she gave birth you
certainly can't know thousands of years
later based on texts that weren't
written until decades or centuries after
it occurred I mean the whole thing is so
obviously nonsensical that it baffles me
that people don't see that and that they
don't have the intellectual honesty to
to engage with religious claims the same
way that we engage with every other
claim in the world in other words be
open to challenging it be open to
defending it and don't throw up the can
out of it the red herring that because
someone questions your faith that that's
evidence of their bigotry that's yes
it's not we've been speaking with Josh
Zepps please make sure to check out his
podcast we the people live Josh wish we
had more time but I really appreciate
you coming on today you know David any
time